all right and our series a more perfect
union we aim to show that what unites us
as Americans is far greater than what
divides us and this morning how art is
creating new connections los
angeles-based graphic designer mural
artist and university instructor Eric
Yonker has found a way to combine his
passion for street art with the black
lives matter movement Younker who is
white teamed up with a young artist
who's black and together they've created
a new mural with a powerful message
Jamie yuccas saw firsthand how the art
is building bridges at the entrance to a
downtown Los Angeles bar Eric younger is
starting a new mural as an artist he
felt compelled to create conversation by
reflecting the pain and unrest set off
by the police killings of George Floyd
Brianna Taylor and countless others it
seems that white people are waking up to
the fact that they play a role in this
yeah it's a 400 year old problem and I
hope that the attention span is there to
keep the momentum going as it gets more
and more uncomfortable is that part of
what this mural is yeah the marchers are
super important and super vibrant and
then what are the next steps to really
affect change and that's voting in art
lecture at USC Yonkers murals cover
walls from the west coast to the east
his designs appear on canvas even wine
bottles but it's visual art in public
places that most excites him it's about
spontaneity and it's about surprise
creativity is taking an idea that's in
your head and making it into a thing
that affects change in the world I
wrestle with the meaning of everything
it's sort of the burden for what I what
artists do I think
as the protests against police grew
louder and angrier
people who follow Yonkers work began
reaching out to ask if he still had the
resist hate posters he'd created
immediately after the divisive 2016
presidential election red is the color
of impact the color of anger the color
fire he now sells the posters to raise
money for the black lives matter
movement modifying the message silence
equals violence earlier this year
Juncker was asked to paint a mural at
safe place for youth in Venice
California an organization that helps
find solutions for young people living
on the streets that's where he met 25
year old Harry Robinson who had been
homeless
I cried myself to sleep a lot of times I
just didn't know why I wasn't working
and like why I had to go through it I
had to be hungry and I just had to like
really learn and appreciate stuff little
things in life Robinson came to Southern
California to escape a rough life in
Indiana all the friends that I grew up
with as we got older they kind of just
chose the wrong paths and if--like I was
becoming a part of that a lot of people
were just dying at early age in my
school everywhere I don't want to die
without trying to chase my dreams I
guess Robinson's number one dream to
paint a mural Jonker made that come true
Robinson connects with its message as an
aspiring artist and musician
is that an important piece right now as
a partnership like the two of you that
you can show people that the differences
aren't really that great between a white
guy and a black guy I haven't thought
about that have you thought about that
no not too much I could just tell like
we both come from two different worlds
and like it's kind of lit that we could
come together make something dope their
masterpiece a cry to protect people of
color from police Jonker is adding a new
name to his mural his great-grandmother
Henriette an actor a black woman from
the Caribbean her father was an escaped
slave race was always part of the family
conversation I was raised with a
grandmother who talked about bricks
coming through the windows in the 1930s
and having bonfires built on their lawn
and stories of my grandfather
straightening his hair and trying to
pass for white in nineteen thirties
forties New York City I'm always
reluctant to talk about it because I'm
still white and I still had white
privilege I have no experience of being
black but I think that's an important
part of the conversation now - yeah I
mean that's part of is figuring out what
those conversations are as part of the
child
the hope is each stroke on this wall
could change people's perceptions and
that just might change the world by
getting people to vote for CBS this
morning Jamie yuccas Los Angeles
Bravo Jamie I think Harry said it best
guys when he said it's kind of lit that
we could come together and create
something dope the two of them clearly
you're on the Sun page when it comes to
art it's such a unifier in such a healer
really nice yeah and Gael coming
together and creating something dope is
a pretty good definition of an election
so people should vote